[Musique]
cette niche très foncée compact et
lourdes est issu d'une vieille tradition
c'est le pain pomme pornic au québec la
pompe une école c'est un sens pour sa de
sel et il ya différentes techniques ou
différent de recettes en fait que je
pourrais dire
daniel de la boulangerie desrosiers
utilisent des grains anciens de seigle
auquel il ajoute comme à l'époque du
sirop de betteraves et de la chapelure
de pain prenez causé chez pour donner de
la texture et du goût la puissance
gustatives de sow est très similaire au
sel alors faut faire attention pour trop
trop amère sinon ça devient très très
fort qu'est ce qui donne la couleur le
noir provient simplement du site naturel
du grain et caraméliser
[Musique]
d'origine allemande le pont rené coll
fait partie de la famille des pins noirs
comme certains autres pains des pays
nordiques
ici on est russe alors ce point là c'est
un levain de seigle mais c'est un pain
avec 90% de blé entier l'eau dce pour ça
c'est de sarrasin de l'ordre outils
qu'on fait routier pour lui donner une
certaine saveur profondeur de saveurs
avec la fenouillet du quart vit dedans
ça c'est un point qui va ressembler plus
à un blé entier traditionnelle qu'on
connaît leroux borg est un est un pain
d'origine danoise
évidemment les danois ont adapté dans le
temps les recettes alors c'est un pain
de seigle d'orge et des spas autres avec
un multi grid les graines de citrouille
de tournesol de ça prend combien tu as à
cuire un point quand soit un pay nous on
est cuit
en dix-huit et vingt-quatre heures
pourquoi cusson si longue c'est qu'à
l'époque on tentait de récupérer la
chaleur résiduelle du four alors nous
disait la température de forme en ce
moment et elle diminue au nez aux points
ne peut plus faire du pain mais le
dernier dix douze treize quatorze heures
de temps qui avait dans cette courbe le
débat nous faut trouver une façon de
faire un pain parce que c'est l'énergie
qu'on voit dans les bois coupé du bourg
fendre le bois le fait sécher le merde
alors il n'y de l'heure comme j'étais
petit j'ai jamais comprendre c'est comme
un pain dans ce qui pèse vraiment look
et dans le wrapping clastiques bizarre
et c'est quand même pas dans la section
de pain c'est vraiment comme la section
de crackers ce genre et quand tu goûtes
ça même sans même industrials même je
pense à bien de l'allemagne car je sais
c'est quand même intéressant c'est
vraiment cool et je pensais un peu ça
que je dis comme ok c'est un challenge
et je vais essayer de la faire
[Musique]
à sa boulangerie jefferies fille quand
steyn à boulange lui aussi le pont peu
d'écho à la façon traditionnelle
il a intégré à son menu des sandwichs
ouvert avec pompe une école qu'il fait
rôtir afin de lui donner encore plus de
goût au niveau de gamme canalisation a
hobo peint ici ont tous et en
fournissant mutsch végétarien ici et
pourquoi en maître avec et noir essai de
balancer tous les sandwichs et ça c'est
vraiment calme je sens bien après mme
roger c'est vraiment un pain qui est
flexible et nourrissant tu manges une
tranche et tu es bon bol d or c'est
vraiment intéressant et c'est de vraie
nourriture pour moi j'ai très très bon
mais tu vois c'est super on peut tout se
décide pas trop sucré mais c'est notre
cheval on goûte les grès beaucoup plus
l'egypte par exemple c'est très
différent que c'est toi on voit qu'à
cinq ans s'est fait avec amour
comme la tradition lancée la cgt avait
pas comme copier ça
pour daniel les pins noirs doivent être
savourée en mangeant cp l'on doit les
femmes seules parce que c'est comme une
bouteille de vin d après soit faire un
agencement qui nous plaît ou comme des
laisses aller notre imagination de dire
où on veut aller avec
c'est le genre de pain que on est prêt
si on n'est pas fou du puy on veut aller
à quelque part d'hommes dans une autre
dimension de vous des saveurs
[Musique]